so has this has the sexting changed
you're returning to our TVs with
marriage boot camp hip hop addition why
the hell did you want to sign yourself
up for this crazy show Phaedra you know
what because they had asked me a few
times and I had to client it so I said
well they said you should ask you know
anyone that you really know and trust
it's our combo because I trust her
judgment and you know I've known her for
years and I said what was it like should
I do it if she said you absolutely
should do it she said it is the best
experience I've ever had on television
but she said Phaedra I made friends for
a lifetime I got real counseling I got
great advice and she said it really
changed my outlook on love and life and
so from that conversation I said you
know what I'm going to do this because
obviously we know everybody knows I know
how to work and I am well prepared to
get a college degree and it made great
business decisions but when it comes to
the relationships I need one-on-one
spending relationships for dummies
because I have not made the best
decisions in that department so you know
and I had a lot of anxiety around dating
and I had been in a relationship with a
guy from Chicago and and and I just
wanted to make better choices and you
know and I knew that from just my past
with relationships I needed help and I
needed real counseling and so that's
what I was seeking to make my next you
know who's my best movies do these Queen
Shayne Baker is back ready to dish
Medina and I have never had sex you
shocked the audience in that first
episode is psy revealing nothing's
happened really no sex has gone down and
I mean this is the thing because my
relationship was tom was very passionate
sometimes passionate blinding and I just
wanted to make sure that we got to know
each other without the physical portion
first because you know I'd already done
that and so one of my girlfriend says a
mistake is something you do once when
you do it twice it becomes a habit and
so I want to make sure that I'm not
getting into a habit of moving too fast
and so you know but Dean is a great guy
and you know with long distance I just I
had to make sure it was right give me
the quick notes of how you two got
together for people who don't know what
we have a mutual the best buddy that
pushed us together and you know he you
know reached out to me on a dating site
but I didn't respond it so then our
mutual friend he called him it was like
what's up with Phaedra he's like he's
like well you know if there was reaching
out her on the same side but she's not
responding say oh hold on so then he
clicks I was like hey you remember but
Dana because I had met him many times in
Atlanta see who see if he's like your
Medina like he's the rich nuts yeah look
his picture right wait so I could
remember and so he's like I'm gonna just
give him your number
no sir so he called me we talked for
three straight hours
Wow yeah it was crazy so we talked to
all those hours then you know from there
he's like hey
Atlanta lay it so how long had you and
Medina been together before you went to
do marriage boot camp we have been
dating for about four months but you
know we were bicoastal and so that's a
little different as well because she's
in LA and I'm in Atlanta so you know
that's hard in itself but he wanted to
move the relationship a little faster
than me and so you know but from my
relationship with tone I knew that I
just needed to not move so fast and make
sure that it was the right relationship
you know if we had crossed all our eyes
and got it out you know that our eyes
crossed our teeth before moving it into
another round if I'm doing my math right
we're approaching almost a year since
you got together are we still together
[Music]
yes we'll be tuning in but I mean it was
there's a very public Instagram that
everybody picked up was like they just
got a new guy then we really haven't
seen him on your Instagram since but I
find that when you are too public and
you post too much it puts too much
scrutiny on the relationship and people
you know wanna make comment so they want
to be very active in you know what's
going on in your private life and so you
know I'm very aware of what I post and I
want to propel people to think about
things that really matter and what I'm
doing in my house and my bed honey is
not matter for the entire world
so the quarantine has obviously put the
brakes on a single another peak but even
if we could I don't know if it's safe
for anyone to be exchanging too much
you mean what work for anybody in your
house okay so has the has the sex thing
changed
I don't know you're asking for full plan
holes of blood work that implies
something Medina how long is long enough
now I mean you're great to me and all
that but green see the but you catch the
but you called the bus my man
the last love was so hurtful I don't
want to make the same mistake you say in
that premiere that you're kind of shy
about getting serious with somebody else
were you able to work through that by
doing the show I really got to know him
on a different level you know because
you know you're dating especially a date
Zico see you know you get off a flag you
know you go out for a nice dinner you
know everything's very pretty you show
your best self all the tools you can't
do when you're living with someone
exactly but you know what I found is I
really could live with it we really got
along so well in those close quarters I
mean it strengthened our in the dude it
just made us totally connect do you see
yourself getting married again
ah honey if someone can handle this
woman have a whole lot of woman and a
little bit of package you know honey but
you know I would love I mean I love the
institution of marriage you know and
marriage is a great thing when it's the
right person and you understand the
business of marriage because marriage is
definitely it's like a partnership right
you know in every sense there's a legal
contract involved so oh yes it is
look with me it'll be a prenup in-law -
can Medina handle all this woman you
know what I think so I've always dated
back and when I say he is so kind so
sweet
tall beautiful a gentleman
I mean it's refreshing I mean it is like
a dip in a a nice cool pond
obviously dating with kids is a whole
other thing because you're a whole
package with two boys when do you know
it's time to introduce them to the man
who's in your life so I don't introduce
them to anyone because first of all you
have to be in a place where I fully
trust you and I know that you're gonna
be a permanent fixture because children
are impressionable they've talked on the
phone but you know no face-to-face
meetings or anything like that because
if we're getting married then that means
hey it's forever bring it back to the
show what did you learn about yourself
from this experience well I've learned
that I could live in a house with a lot
of different crazy people but really as
far as me personally I'm very type A and
I'm very much a perfectionist and maybe
in love there isn't the perfect
situation you just sort of have to adapt
to it and so I think that's what I
really learned about myself is
everything can't be you know black away
or just perfect at all times I gotta ask
cuz it's that time of year again where
people are speculating about who's on
Housewives who's not everybody wants you
back do you even want to go back to that
show you know what it's flattering that
you know people often ask about these
you know right now I'm trying to find
love I mean that's where my focus isn't
fighting love and so it's flattering
that you know people think of me when
they think of a housewife it was a great
experience
you you're not saying no but you're not
saying yes either um this is the thing
life is about growth and so you know I'm
not a one-dimensional person and so
you've got to do things that are in the
best interest of who you want to be and
as a parent who you want your children
to see you ask and so as a mother I want
to do things that my children can always
look back on and be very proud and so
you know I'm at a point now my god my
little guys are seven and ten and so we
make decisions as a family and so you
know when I decided to go marriage boot
camp we had a very long conversation
about it because I explained to them
what Mommy was doing and they were okay
with it and so no that's that's where I
am with all of my decisions it has to be
the best thing for me as a parent
parenting to African American boy said
to be you know the president and okay
[Music]